[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right you want to help me push this
er yes so it's been about two weeks
since we've last filmed my parents left
and we have just gone absolutely crazy
on the cabin and it is becoming complete
keep it steady slow down girl
sheesh I went into town which is hours
away to go antique shopping so I went
and bought a ton of furniture I haven't
seen it in there yet so once we're done
with the interior I get to bring it to
him
still left to do the list is now down to
like 100 things we got to get all this
done in time because my really good
friend Steve who banged Eva Tanguay who
travels around the world with me and
shoots photos is flying out here to come
shoot the cabin and reveal it to the
world so we have to get going
towards you yeah
I have a good job today because I get to
stay nice and toasty and he has to work
outside like a glove yes ma'am good work
right now we're finishing up the trim
we're almost done with the trim inside
we just have this little bit to go I'll
be screwing well he's cutting how close
is that to my eye tell me when to stop I
trust you hey I'm screwing is it okay
that it's like a little off yeah that's
my name a little off whistling screw her
off so basically I'll tell you what to
do yeah you do your job up in life one
and a half rip some1
a stock let's go do that right now
that's know I'm afraid to do it see once
bitten twice sure I know I'm gonna do it
again I've been listening to a lot of
books on tape with this an English
narrator he's so good
sounded prevel check me out some of them
right that's you a cabin bro last two
pieces of trim this next piece is gonna
go up over here and cover up the gap
between the wall material and the door
jamb right there and applause for every
screw we put in is the last one
on the inside see how quick takes you
take the wind out of my cell
nice I love it
okay so we got all the trim on the
inside onto the next thing on our
laundry list
the dining table huh it's a coffee table
you keep on singing dining room table
but I guess it is on camera we I guess
we are going to dine on a coffee table
so it is like our coffee table is their
dining table we're all done with the
interior and now I need a coffee table
he did not like the coffee table that I
went and drove three and a half hours
ago should be flat so it's one of the
things that I'm kind of like traditional
about a competition call me
old-fashioned but that one that you got
looks like someone like went into their
firewood pile and they got two pieces of
firewood and they screw them together
it's not that I love the table it was
just cheap you know like this whoa it's
not table you go shopping next time
you're a Jared sorry
all right there's some fatty bow bodies
over here we should take measure you
want some of these
I want the live edge oh yeah this is a
one this is really big and wide that one
down there at the bottom of courses at
the bottom this lumber is from the pole
structure that was here that we ripped
down
[Music]
so what about this mold is that
worrisome okay where are we going back
to the cabin
[Music]
yeah it's beautiful thank you it's gonna
look so good
Steve our photographer is coming and we
still have so much to do you have a lot
to do we have to finish the siding
finish the door clean up decorate a lot
but we're gonna do it and we just have
to get to work Jesus scared me one time
oh my my mom said if you have a song in
your heart you should sing it I have
some really dorky math thing to say
right now but I'm not gonna say cuz
remember yesterday when uh we were
talking about the door trim we're
getting the angle 25 when I get my
angles 35 yeah guess what this trim
angle is right here 25 and 35 yes
that's math it's not magic it's mad do
you love math
uh-huh good answer you know what I was
talking about math and I messed up I'm
like really high on the ladder and
freaking out right now so if you could
not scream and yell that would be
helpful
I like to make these cuts I'm gonna need
eight pieces that have this ten degree
bevel on it so I'm gonna cut eight
pieces like that so I don't have to keep
on switching back and forth with the saw
blade I'm about at the point where I
can't do any more because my knees start
knocking it's too high
nope those all have tongues on them this
one has a tongue ripped off we had to
rip their tongues off before we could
use them we had to rip their tongues off
they're tongueless boards ain't talking
to nobody no more checkmate I don't have
any pouches for it so I got to bring it
up like this the beautiful Pelt you're
doing that wasn't way more style than I
do boom
yeah the bucket not my style the book is
just not my style girl I mean as long as
you don't care about like a thousand
bucks crawling all over you
no I cannot about a thousand bugs for I
have seen the underside of the moss know
how precious it is and all that dwells
within you
who does question them off
[Music]
that's a little bit Wow
just as the last patch of moss goes in I
look up and there's an a bald eagle
flying above epic
you call this a couch but that's being
pretty generous it's a very small Blum
State for a very small cabin Wow
all right before we bring out anything
else we need to clean let's clean this
place up okay and then we'll bring it
all up all right I'm sweeping and
cleaning up so we can bring all the
furniture in and start decorating that
skin this is gonna be the first time I
see everything laid out in this space I
did the measurements the best I could I
really hope that everything fits and it
doesn't look crazy and couch is too big
or chair is too small so you sound
really positive and hopeful about
everything fitting and maybe like if you
think it actually might which is awesome
because I seem to remember you thought
that I was out of my mind
couch chair table yes I will admit now
that it's it's built it does seem that
all those things will fit they might fit
so well I'm not gloating or anything
actually shouting oh babe thank you so
much you're so sweet for saying that I
just was I was actually legit without
any sarcasm in my voice saying Wow cool
[Music]
let's hope there's enough space good
grief
that's really good oh that's where that
lamp goes higher so I bought it in table
I showed it to Jacob he really just
liked it
so was maybe a little bit too harsh and
then promised to make an end table and
that's what I'm gonna have to do right
here but it's no big deal she found this
piece of wood
it's gorgeous it'll be easy-peasy it's
the shelves around the back that's what
I think is gonna take some time that's
kind of hard so don't forget I need some
shelves over there
[Music]
I'm gonna appreciate it later but not
right now I'll trim it out yes
that's why I wasn't talking that's why
you thought I was really mad can't win
this chicken oh man we're sleeping out
here tonight it's so warm up here - oh
look at that you did a really good job
just works
you mean the colors yeah like all of it
yeah I can't wait to see the downstairs
as decorated as the upstairs this is
beautiful
this is the very last thing that I like
to do when making the cabin is design
the pattern that's gonna go on the door
it's the centerpiece it's like the first
thing that you see it's the portal to
enter the cabin it's so important that
this is special we got this rough sawn
lumber from the local folks down the
street but it's all different
thicknesses and widths and all of that
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take each of these pieces and mill them
up until there are a lot of pieces like
this that are the exact same width same
thickness and then we're going to design
the door pattern you get to put on these
ones and go into a totally different
world now I'm going to pump some
somewhere I might have put on some Tom
Petty right now it's so low I feel like
I'm seeing him live cuz I'm free
[Music]
I'm not an interior designer I don't
know what I'm doing but I have decorated
my own apartments before and my style is
kind of bohemian with some lot just
everything kind of makes sense let's be
different in this cabin this cabin is
very masculine all the wood everywhere
in the sharp hard angles like I just
wanted to soften it so I kind of just
did this like eclectic a little bit more
feminine unexpected bohemian kind of
look in here and I think it looks great
and it's different and Jacob will love
that because he likes different so
we're gonna have enough wood just barely
just barely enough yes scraps yes
oh no it's not long enough that one is
that one is that one is there's a knob
[Applause]
Oh baby come on where's the next one six
five four three two oh oh yeah I forgot
to cut that one it's getting down to the
wire it's getting dark I'm cleaning up
while Jacobs finishing up the doors and
as soon as we're done with that we'll be
ready for Steve first thing in the
morning for sunrise now I'm going to
just tap around give it a little tap it
it just tap it in tappy tappy another
New Englander and I'm saying there I
ever heard of it
[Music]
[Music]
you like eBay oh my god it's beautiful
you did it again every little piece of
this cabin last night we picked up all
the tools we brought the tent bag picked
up a little scrap pieces of wood cleaned
up as best we could and then it got dark
so we couldn't really see what we were
doing so that's why I got out here early
and him fixing up the trails because
everyone's gonna show up in a minute
even my friend yes what do you think
we're gonna get you like renting
nice I like that I got you know with
your missing thing blowing okay cool I
love that you probably won't see my feet
right like if it's from the back yeah
well great I'll take my shoes off so I
ordered all these like fairytale dresses
to shoot for the cabin but forgot to
order cute shoes all I have is like my
work boots here so hopefully he's
shooting from the knee up or I'll just
be barefoot on this frozen ground okay
oh god that's cold okay yeah
[Music]
can I see how my dresses going oh cool
stop it I love it Steve she didn't play
sports going
we're running weird so it bounces she
didn't play field hockey shut up Sarah
and this dress is like princess
Buttercup and she's just been running
through the woods she escapes the evil
Prince and she's running through the
woods and now look she's found this
cabin in the woods and then now she's
just peeked inside to see is there a
monster within or is there a hero or is
there just some dirty carpenter who kind
of smells
[Music]
we're trying to recreate American Gothic
painting with the older man and woman
standing front of their house at the
pitch part this has actually been a very
useful tool for spreading these cedar
wood chips but so we've had it handy
that's it we got it all the way out man
this is crazy being out here finally we
have everything built Steve's taking the
pictures and we're actually out here for
the first time getting to absorb it and
take it all in and I am speechless it's
crazy seeing it without like tools and
ladders and like cut out pieces of wood
there's it's crazy it looks like now it
was just like locked out here instead of
like obviously a construction still that
for me that's it I said this is a mural
and we've only done a section of it you
know like cabin land is like a large
canvas
[Music]
we were both really afraid to do this I
think fear can keep you from doing a lot
of things in life we had all those
things like tenfold but we still went
for it
you know like life is short why the heck
not and so I hope that many people watch
this they get inspired by that too
yes
a second
first night in the new cabin yes first
night in the first cabin you just
finished it we finally get to enjoy it
we're out of the airstream check this
out it's so cozy and so much more
spacious than the earth yeah you you
might not believe it but it's way more
space she didn't think it was gonna be
but it's way more spacious yes thank you
so much everyone for following along and
on this journey it's been amazing we
have plans for the next cabin already
it's going to actually be the managers
residence the managers house why is it
why is that the one we're building next
well it may be we'll see hopefully we
might we have crazy plans no matter what
they're coming out of our ears so we
haven't decided what's next go we got
lots of blood yeah but basically we'd
like it to be the big house so we can
kind of get out of the airstream
permanently and have a shower and a
laundry all of those wonderful things
[Music]
next we are gonna keep creating cabin
hope that you follow along and stick
with us for the rest
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please